[Musique]
la réserve naturelle nationale de
l'étang saint-paul ouvre les festivités
de ses 10 ans avec l'organisation de la
première édition de la fête de l'étang
saint paul cette première édition a pour
but de valoriser les plus grandes zones
humides des mascareignes suis à cet
événement je souhaite vous parler un peu
de l'étang saint-paul l'étang saint paul
la plus grande zone humide est la mieux
préservée des mascareignes
c'était en naturel créé il y a seulement
2200 102 mille deux cents ans accueillis
et nourrit les premiers habitants de
l'île sur le lieu même de notre
rencontre aujourd'hui cette fête qui se
veut populaire s'inscrit dans une
démarche en faveur de la protection de
l'environnement et de la biodiversité
ainsi que sont une quarantaine
d'animations qui sont proposés
gratuitement sur les deux jours et tous
les temps peuvent rentrer dans la
fabrication de papier les déchets de
deux pestes végétales les déchets de
papier de bureau donc voilà pour
refabriquer soit du papier soit des
objets soient des barquettes
alimentaires donc voilà on a des projets
dans ce sens cette manifestation cherche
également à célébrer la nature et des
liens qu'entretiennent les réunionnais
avec elle la réserve naturelle existe
depuis dix ans nous avons pu réaliser
cette fête grâce aux habitants de la
grande fontaine de la payait de boulons
nous faisons un travail de terrain
avec la réserve et avec la population de
ces quartiers dont je viens de citer
mais notre devise est la phrase suivante
tout ce que nous faisons pour vous sans
nous et toujours contre nous donc moi je
souhaite que la réserve soit actrice et
si dans ce dossier de la préservation de
l'écosystème uma de toute la nature
le conseil départemental partenaire
indispensable pour préserver et
valoriser les espaces naturels sensibles
c'est ce que nous rappelle le président
du département monsieur série de métier
en soi le département participe à ce
genre de projet parce que nous sommes
nous mêmes propriétaires de près de 40%
de la surface de l'étang ici à saint
paul au titre des espaces naturels
sensibles le département fait partie du
conseil de la régie de l'étang et il
était important que au même titre que la
commune de saint-paul et l'état qu'on
soit présent nous sommes présents parce
qu'il s'agit de préserver de valoriser
cet espace remarquable de l'étang saint
paul avec l'un des plans d'eau les plus
importantes de toute la zone des
mascareignes et préserver valoriser mais
en même temps permettre aux familles de
la réunion de venir à la découverte de
ces espaces à travers des sentiers de
randonnée à travers des aires de pique
nique
nous à la réunion je voulais dire on
aime bien pique-niqué on aime bien
partager des moments en famille et on
peut le faire autour de l'étang saint
paul dans des zones aménagées
tout cela participe donc d'une volonté
du département de faire découvrir
l'arena de permettre aux réunionnaises
et réunionnais de bien manger bien
bouger sur des sites naturels bien
entretenu
[Musique]